yeah welcome to this video playing F
Drive maybe it's a sign you know I've
played the Sicilian relatively
infrequently yeah that's what you get
for doing it okay okay maybe I can
transpose into a French if I know we get
this isolated or with the Queen I don't
care come on this kind of position is
not not the most dangerous ever for
blanket it's um it's quite playable the
important difference to the French is
that here because white is played c3
this is very close to a French
tirage because white is played c3 black
actually gets the time to play Knight at
five preventing Bishop III and this
means you could use me to add the chance
to put it on b6 not on d6 the bishop and
it's much better on b6 on d6 after
Knight f5 it's not so clear how white
should develop young miss Bishop decided
on that
I'm intending Bishop e6 okay I can't I
can't do that Queen here Bishop e6 roopd
eight yeah this is in fact an
interesting plan the same this idea with
them the possible Queen to d3 d4 Knight
h4 was good for black
and this almost could be a theoretical
position don't know okay man this is
good probably good noodles you're taking
in the pawn
yeah if I go King to h7 he might take a
five or take age six
what about g5 is this is this terrible
I don't know it's interesting I mean I
get the bishop at least oh yeah no this
this shouldn't be shouldn't be too bad
how to proceed now
should I play D form to activate and
prevent my to deform yeah this is the
most activist yeah the other one of
course this was too quick Queen d3 now
Queen d3 was interesting
with the maid threat
hmm
yeah it's still it's still possible 23
and I don't have a great way to prevent
it maybe at some point is in going to PC
I'm going to play it
I have fun yeah I don't have enough
compensation from the porn but it's
still playable with two bishops
check
hmm
who isn't this in this tricky at least a
bit tricky maybe this one it takes
Bishop c7 doesn't
hmm yeah cannot play h5
maybe do this sir cautionary get out of
the check so let him make a move I'm
intending h4 h4 h5 h4 yeah it isn't it
isn't completely clear cut her what
should win here he is better but is he
winning
on the Queen move I can maybe even take
and play bookie to or something like
that maybe it's not at all easy not to
make a move a good one yeah this is a
possible team but even the Queen trade
isn't isn't clear it's not threatening
anything
Bishop c7 rook g3 in an ideal world I
get I get to this
hmm it is threatened now Group g3
hmm
my can take and it's not bad but of
course I may be there so since some
other tricky idea
this should afford certain No
Queen h4 check time warning I made yeah
somehow tricked tricked tricked out of
this positioning challenge
oops some other challenge um yeah this
was lucky of course I mean like his like
his worse but let's let's excel in this
position with rookie three yeses so bad
rookie three I have so Bishop f5 is the
key to this position and this wins for
white there should be five
hmm yeah yeah we should fight this much
stronger what am I supposed to do now if
I take yeah this is just all so
chemistry 3 I have no big idea now can
we treat but how does how do I get
counterplay now this is just an
excellent piece Bishop f5 was strong
after this
played here yo T I probably should take
h6 with the noid this has given us a
draw by the computer but this this
losses yeah yeah now Blake is winning
thanks a lot
this is also quite quite strange because
this this sorts of protecting h6 so he's
got no way out of this really knows the
compounds to play creature here check
check
which of course I didn't see at all
check
yeah this is an amazing handmade so I
need to give it up and at the end this
is good for black yeah I've got an extra
pawn and this is probably falling yeah
of course I didn't see any of that but
it was working just it was working
nicely yeah he had this this big shot at
the game with Bishop f5 which shows was
very strong instead of this or one move
already I even Fisher at five it was was
strong thanks for watching